hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so what we're going to talk
about in this video is which way does
the hyperbola open this is a question
that a lot of times students get
confused by because they start learning
about ellipses and parabolas and
hyperbolas and circles all at the same
time and so they get some of the rules
and formulas confused a little bit so
let me see if I can clear that up in
this video here for you so what we're
going to be looking at are these two
equations here this one and this one and
what I want you to notice is that with
hyperbolas you're always subtracting
okay they always equal one just like
ellipses but whichever term is first
whichever term is positive okay that's
going to determine the direction that
the hyperbola opens so if the x squared
is a positive term it comes first here
it's going to open in the x-axis
Direction horizontally left and right if
the Y squared is the positive term that
one comes first right then it's going to
be opening in the Y direction the
vertical direction up and down okay it's
like along the y axis like that that
direction so it's easy to remember x
squared it's kind of opening like the
direction x axis goes left and right Y
squared is positive it opens up and down
and one thing that students also you can
get confused about is that a squared + B
squared with ellipses whichever
denominator is larger that's your a
squared but with hyperbolas a squared is
always going to be underneath the
positive term and what the a represents
it represents the distance from the
center to the vertices so this distance
from here to here is a this distance
from here to here is a okay so it
doesn't matter which one's larger it
just matters which one is underneath the
positive term I'll show you what I mean
in these couple examples here so this
first one you can see x squared is
positive it comes first and that tells
us it's going to be opening in the x
axis direction so what we're going to do
is we're going to see that the a value
is actually 3 because the square root of
9 is 3 and so from the center we're
going to go right 3 left 3 those are
going to be our vertices right there
this is our B squared the square root of
16 is 4 so we're going to be going 4 in
the Y direction
okay one two three four and we're gonna
be drawing this dotted rectangle and all
this does is it just helps us to find
the asymptotes they go through the
corners of the rectangle also through
the center point and it give us a sense
of how wide or narrow the hyperbola is
so this hyperbola is going to be opening
like this getting closer and closer to
the asymptotes but it's not going to
cross them it just gives us a sense of
how wide it is now you can check out
I'll have a link to one of my other
videos where I go more into how to find
the equations of the asymptotes and the
foci and all that other good stuff about
hyperbolas but for this video I just
want to show you you know the direction
because that's the question that
students often have so in this last
example notice that the Y squared is
positive that tells us it's going to
open in the y axis Direction vertically
and the a squared is 4 so from the
center we're going to go up two and down
two and in the x direction we're going
to go right 1 and left 1 because the
square root of 1 is 1 and that just
allows us to draw this you know dotted
or dashed rectangle it's just invisible
it's just imaginary we're just using it
as a guide to draw our asymptotes and
you can see it's going to be opening
like this ok and that's it so I hope
this video helped you to understand how
to work with hyper beause a little bit
you know easier go ahead and check out
the other video I did on hyperbolas and
some of the other conic sections I'll
have a link for that and I'll talk to
you the next video I'll talk to you soon